the reason they gave an emotional
resignation speech this week saying that
being Prime Minister had been the honor
of her life and we can speak to someone
who perhaps knows mrs. May more than
most the former Deputy Prime Minister
and university friend with a prime
minister Damian Green thank you very
much for being with us this morning as
someone who's a friend of Teresa may how
was it watching that speech that she
gave when she announced her resignation
no face add that as she said this was a
huge honor to be Prime Minister she
regarded that I think everyone has
commented on her sense of duty which
which was there literally to the end and
and we saw it was a fairly emotional end
to that speech and any decent person
would have thought that's that's very
sad did she speak to you before she made
up her mind no I haven't spoken to in
the last few days but I think to some
extent it became inevitable that the the
deal as devised wasn't gonna go through
Parliament so her prime ministership had
reached the end of the road how do you
think she will be feeling now I mean
obviously she was she was saying how it
was the owner of her life she was
talking about the things that she felt
she'd achieved in office
it felt to me watching it that there was
perhaps a tinge of regret that she
hadn't had enough opportunity to focus
on some of her domestic agenda I think
that's right and and I share that
feeling that we all remember the speech
she made when she went into Downing
Street the attack on the burning
injustice is it felt like a different
type of conservatism one that was
reaching out if you like beyond the
conservative call though beyond the
heartlands for to the whole and now the
attractive vision and because brexit
came to dominate everything she wasn't
able to make anything like enough
progress on any of those things that she
really cared about remembered I guess
too early to say I think to some extent
it depends on on the next leader because
if we can get brexit through and then
move on to a new modern agenda that
looks to the future then it will be seen
as a tough period that maybe we want to
go through but but so in an odd way the
success of the next leader will I think
helped
her place in history well let's talk
about that who do you think should be
the next leader I think the next leader
should be Matt Hancock I do think we
need a fresh start
I think we need somebody obviously
getting brexit through is the immediate
task but we've got to start thinking and
caring about more than that looking
through to the 2020s and I think it's
important for the Conservative Party now
which is done is doing so badly among
young voters in particular to have
somebody who can can speak the language
of those who grew up in the digital
world and who evidently is competent and
on top of issues of technology and how
it applies to people's real lives as
health secretary he's shown that having
new advanced technology in the NHS
actually improves healthcare so you can
apply this knowledge to a wide range of
of the key public services that we as
conservators have got to show we've got
answers to listen to what you're saying
and also to his kind of pitch yesterday
it's clear that he's trying to position
himself as a leader for the future but
realistically is he ever gonna win with
the membership I think we can have a
quick look and at a poll of members
which this is back in January but if
anything I'd imagine that the No Deal
support has grown 57% saying they're
brexit preference is No Deal I mean are
they really going to back someone who
supported remain in the referendum well
I think one of the if you like that the
most dangerous pieces of analysis for
the future the Conservative Party is
simply to keep people in a spec saying
what you did in June 2016 is all that
matters so I can see that that's what
you would like the situation to be but
in reality that we are fighting on
brexit now aren't we well we've got to
get brexit through that that's
absolutely clear but one of the that
mean the problem with No Deal as we all
know is that you won't get that through
the House of Commons so if you have
people who are promising and No Deal
brexit then the the extreme likelihood
is that that various people will find
ways of stopping it going to the House
of Commons and therefore you will have
to go to a general election and I think
those are nice the country certainly
doesn't want that
like the conservative part well I think
he
put it this way there has to be the
possibility that we would see Jeremy
Corbyn in Downing Street and clearly no
conservative wants that so we have to
approach the the brexit conundrum in an
intelligent way you've written today in
a piece in The Sunday Times and the
future survival of the Conservative
Party is at risk a polarizing leader
would be the final straw if a future
survival is at risk is that what I feel
that that very very strongly you've seen
the figures now that the average age at
which people are more like he's vote
conservative than not has gone up to 51
you know we talk about young voters
we're talking about anyone under the age
of 50 here so it's absolutely kids but
it's one of the reasons I'm supporting
that Hancock that I think the
combination of the policy ideas he has
and his approach and style to politics
can actually expand the the conservative
vote in a way that is of supreme
importance to the future the party at
the end half of that quote a polarizing
leader will be the final straw who could
she be talking about well I'll be
talking about any of the candidates who
go down that route we have at the start
so anyone who is talking about leaving
with no deal at the end of October is
that what you defined as polarizing
somebody who says that you know some
conservatives are less good than other
conservatives when one of the other
things I say in in masculine Sunday
times is that the Conservative Party is
at its best and the Conservative Party
only joined many years ago was a party
where Dan Hannon and Dominic grieve can
feel equally at home because actually we
agree on lots of things we don't agree
between ourselves on brexit that's why
we've got to we've got to get out of the
European Union we've got to respect the
referendum it would be much better to do
that smoothly with the deal and then get
on to the many other things that people
really care about in their daily lives
okay let's let's stop skirting around
that you talk about Boris Johnson no I'm
not talking about poet I think it's very
very important that particularly at the
phase where we've got many candidates in
this election that we set out the
principles so you give very much I think
there are many of the people who are
running would be good prime ministers
there's actually there's there's a wide
field
but also a good field and I think the
best of that field is Matt Hancock and
one of the rules I'm going to operate
through this campaign is that I am NOT
going to diss colleagues Ronald Reagan
had this with this famous rule that you
should never be rude about another
Republican in public and I'm going to
apply that to conservatives as well